um and in all of the instances
i feel like i mean there's tons of
things you can learn from a man like
that but
the big thing that i was able to take
away was
[Music]
what's going on everyone happy thursday
i have a good one for you today
um i'm calling this violence is the
answer and what i
learned from having four meetings with
arnold schwarzenegger so um i haven't
talked a lot about
the stuff that we do with the charity um
and i don't know why i haven't done it i
think it was just because i never
uh i didn't want it to feel like we were
bragging about anything like that i
think that's why i haven't discussed it
as much
um but that being said um i've got a ton
of things that have been on my mind
and a bunch of lessons that i think that
i took from speaking with arnold we had
a breakfast together that was two hours
long
we went to his house uh uh less than a
month ago
two weeks ago um and in all of the
instances
i feel like i mean there's tons of
things you can learn from a man like
that but
the big thing that i was able to take
away was
um i want to call it like the optimist
like a delusion of optimism
and what i mean by that is that once
like the higher the level of success
that you achieve
the more noise and hate you will receive
right and so if you think about like the
amount of security we had to go through
to to get into arnold's house and all of
those things just like
just befitting of the fact that there
are people out there who sent him death
threats every day for just existing
right because they watched a movie and
their wife divorced someone for who
looked like him right
and so the that kind of leads to the
second thing which is
the more impact you have the more
impressions you make
based on the skill that you have it's
just law of a large number it's going to
be a larger percentage of bat [ __ ] crazy
people that you got to deal with
right and so if for some reason
the negativity of a trainer or a
competitor
or a client drags you down then you
don't have the mental fortitude for the
success that you want to achieve
because the condition of that success is
more not less
of the hate of the [ __ ] of the noise
that you're currently dealing with
it doesn't go away it gets louder and
louder and louder
and so one of the one of the the skills
or the disciplines that we have to
develop as entrepreneurs especially if
we seek
this impact and that's with so many
people that i talk to so many
entrepreneurs like i want to impact
i want to help 10 000 people i want to
transform lives if you want to help 10
000 people
then you have to be prepared to have 500
people who [ __ ] hate you
all right because anyone who does
anything worth doing
is going to have an equal and opposite
reaction right
that's how it is if you look at every
single great religious leader that's
ever happened and it doesn't really
matter
almost all of them died right and were
murdered
for what they did and most people would
argue that they were probably good
people
but with every positive thing that you
do there's going to be an equal
uh reaction that's negative right and so
it's a it's like i just want to say this
sentence to you because it means so much
to me is that
hatred is a condition of success it's a
condition
if you have no hatred if you have no
people who hate you who talk against you
speak
against you then it means you're
standing for nothing
like you're standing for nothing because
if if there is nothing for anyone to
debate against you
then you stand for nothing and that
means that you're not actually having
any impact
and so if you fear that kind of
confrontation if you fear that kind of
hate
that kind of of whatever then you need
to not be in business or you need to fix
that part of yourself
because you will sabotage your own
success you will become successful the
noise and the hatred and the naysayers
will increase and then you will make
yourself less successful so that you
don't have to deal with it
right that's that's like real right
that's what happens
and so just just some of the mental
things that i've
that i've you know had to go you know
like you have trainers and you have
clients
you know whatever it is right the gyms
one thing that i've seen with arnold and
on the flip side
trump right and they don't like each
other they're like arnold's outspoken
against trump and all that kind of stuff
but one thing that they both share that
i really admire
is almost a delusional optimism is that
they all they almost don't even they
they don't even address it they don't
even acknowledge the presence of haters
they're just like like if you see trump
get attacked
he just won't even acknowledge it right
and listen i've never voted i don't care
right but the point is like their
level of of mental fortitude of being
able to just exist on a plane that's
above
everyone else above all the noise is the
condition for them being able to achieve
the levels that they've been able to
achieve
right and so one of the things about
this that that gives me solace
is that none of the hatred none of the
the the trainer who leaves and starts
talking [ __ ] about you none of the
clients who leave and talk [ __ ] about
you
none of that ever affects your business
it only affects you
right and so um i think i think layla
made a post
um i don't know a week or two ago about
like
she was basically like if anyone talks
[ __ ] about you it's because when they
talk about themselves no one gives a
[ __ ]
right that's what they said or that's
what her quote said and she had like
seven different people message her
people who were talking [ __ ] about us
that we had no idea existed
and so she was like god i'm never gonna
make that post again right
but the thing is is that this is the
record this is a record month for us
this is the best month in sales we've
ever had
right and amid that this was when she
posted this post and there's all this
negativity and so
you have to remember that if there is
negativity there's also
positivity that's coming with it because
as as ugly as this sounds
there really is no negative publicity
like you know this from the from the
freaking presidential election
right he won because there was he owned
the conversation good and bad he owned
it all
right and if everyone is talking about
you
guess who they're not talking about
anyone else right
and so you have to be polar you have to
stand for things because that is
going to bring the haters out and you
should welcome it you should be like
thank you for thinking about me i
appreciate that
thank you we had a record salesman this
month keep talking about me i love it
like feeding my bank account keep going
dude keep going
it's awesome right and so
understanding that the law of large
numbers is that the more people you
impact
right the more by percentage you're
going to rub the wrong way and so
just like accept it and then always put
things in context
all right and so when we have our we had
our quarterly meeting
whenever uh you know someone from the
front line or something from management
comes up with somebody's like i think
this is a problem i always ask all right
what's the number of incidences
and then how many total incidences do we
and then how many total people
who could potentially have an incident
um
are are there right so i'll give you an
example um
we had someone who's a manager who um
was saying
uh we had a gym owner who can complain
about paypal that like getting paid out
from paypal on the prestige laptop he
said i don't want to sign up
um because you guys pay for paypal and i
i paid paypal
and she was like it really bothered me
and i was like well how many people has
this been
she's like so i think we should consider
switching from paypal it's like well
how many people has this been an issue
and she was like well one
like how many active affiliates we have
a thousand so point
one percent of people had a problem with
it
like don't even let it touch you you
know what i mean don't even let it touch
your thought your mind because when you
have scale you have
200 clients if you have five [ __ ]
think about it
it's two and a half percent of your
entire clientele base
what percentage of humans do you think
are kind of crazy
i would say at least two and a half
percent at least
right and so if you can if you can
always
take apart the problems that arise or
that people bring to you and think about
it in context of the larger numbers that
you're dealing with
i promise you will make the noise of the
world go down
and you'll be able to get to that to
ascend to that higher level and
eventually we can get to the spiritual
plane of
arnold and trump and whatever you feel
about them i don't care
it's just you can appreciate the fact
that they can exist on another plane
and literally just live in a world of
delusion where like they're untouchable
because they they put themselves in this
box and there is a borderline where it
does become delusional because you don't
take feedback but
because the hate is so loud they almost
can't allow it
right like arnold was attacked at the
arnold expo where he's like
cheering kids on you know what i mean
like people are crazy and you just gotta
accept that
so um let me make sure i hit all my my
lovely points
um
yeah and so the only thing that you have
left to do
um that actually drives your business is
the four numbers that i brought up the
other day
is any of these things going to drive
more applications
is it going to drive a higher percentage
of close is it going to decrease my
churn
is it getting smart increase my
profitability and the believe it or not
the haters right that you have the
trainers the ex clients the whatever
right
the likelihood that they're going to
really impact like that they
know the majority of the marketplace is
basically zero
right like if you have a client who
leaves it mind you i
like i'm not talking about any specific
client because like i'm talking about
the gyms
i'm saying like if you have a client at
your gym who leaves right and they they
know
10 people they know 20 people they start
making posts right
people only remember how they feel when
they read that
no one ever remembers what any [ __ ]
talker talks about they only remember
the negativity and they associate it
with the person who's talking [ __ ]
which is why one of the biggest issues
that i had early on in my life i was
telling you is that i used to talk [ __ ]
and it was like something that i really
hated about myself and so
the rule that i made is that if i am
going to say something that is negative
i'm going to say to the person first and
then if i am so if i do tell someone
else i'm like hey by the way i've
already told this person this
this is what i think about and so that's
kind of given me my like
i don't see [ __ ] unless i've told the
person about what i believe
right and so that's kind of my my rule
of thumb for
[ __ ] talking but um i say all that to
say
that person who's left your business
that client or whatever
knows 20 people your ads are reaching 50
000 people a day
what actual impact do you think they
have
none and so you got to think about it in
terms of math right because it will
literally just like put you at ease
because you realize that
the things that matter in the business
are the things that matter
this video is not going to drive sales
for me right i make these partially for
me because i like documenting the
journey and i want to look back that's
actually why i do this
right um but me posting on instagram
doesn't do [ __ ]
right it doesn't do anything right these
don't really do much
the things that do are the things of
doing the boring work
of making sure that we refresh our ad
content make sure we have good offers
make sure that the leads are getting
worked make sure that we're following up
make sure that when we're on the sales
calls
we're clarifying whether they're
labeling with a mobile problem we're
going over their past paid
and we're selling them the vacation and
making sure that we can explain how we
can fill the gap
right the fundamentals and all scale is
is doing the fundamentals
in larger numbers that is all it is and
there's complexity in that but the
process from a mental standpoint is
simple
right and so that is what's going to
grow your business and so if you
get distracted and you have somebody
who's bugging you you have a trainer you
have a client or whatever it is
just go back to your numbers and focus
on the things that drive your business
because i can tell you that a any person
who's speaking against you
is is is confirming the fact that you
are being successful
it's a condition it's a condition of
success if you stand for nothing no one
stands against you
period it's what it is right so first
they're confirming that you're actually
having impact
second they're bringing top of mind
awareness they're talking about you all
the time
great and then third it doesn't matter
anyways
all of it doesn't even matter because
none of it is impacting the things that
grow your business
and so just remember that when you're
spending 100 a day
you're buying 2 000 impressions you're
buying 2
000 people and you're buying it every
day right sorry 25
5 000 impressions so you're buying 5 000
eyeballs right
and this person's organic reach is like
[ __ ] 100 it doesn't
matter and so just like put it to rest
just stop worrying about it like i can't
tell you like it
got to the point where people would ask
me they're like hey do you want me to
like send you this
this stuff for other people i was like
nah man i've been doing this
two and a half years and when i came out
i was talking against things that people
didn't like there was a lot of gurus who
were established when i came into this
three years ago i was like i don't think
lbos work here's why
this is math right and they started
bashing and that's like that's cool but
the math is wrong
right like i'm gonna be right what they
should have done was copy my [ __ ] that's
what they should have done
and they did it they postured against
with pride which is the wrong move
and so i'm totally going another
direction but we're just gonna rock with
it
so like from a strategy standpoint right
if you're the small player what you want
to do
is you want to attack the methodology of
the bigger player that's what you should
do
right but you better be right
and you have to have a unique angle of
why yours is better and different
right now if you're the incumbent
there's virtually no reason that the
incumbent the person who's established
in the market should ever lose
the only reason they lose is because
they're human and because they're human
because they're prideful
and because they don't want to accept
that they're wrong there could be
another way
right because technically the winner
should do exactly what you see amazon
doing
they let someone come up with something
and then boom they rip off and they copy
it
right and then that guy's gone because
they own the entire distribution network
and so real talk there hasn't been
anything that has come out
from anyone that i have seen and i know
because i buy everything
right that has been useful right not
really
and so i see everything and
i will not let someone do to me what i
did
to the people before me which was attack
attack attack the methodology because
you don't want to be the type of person
who attacks on this character it's just
it's it literally never looks good
it's a losing battle makes you look like
an ass no one remembers who you're
attacking they just remember the churn
[ __ ]
right so wrong strategy that way you do
want to attack the methodology
if you have a superior option but the
problem is if you attack it loud enough
and the eye of sauron comes to you and
sees what you're doing what they should
do
the strategic move is to take it
distribute it and then wipe you out
that is how that's the game like that's
the game theory and like
that's how you win and so the only way
to
beat the incumbent is also for the
account that's why that's why amazon
trades
like a zillion times its actual earnings
because no one knows how they can beat
them
how do you beat them they don't have an
ego about it they don't give [ __ ]
they're like cool you found a new toilet
paper brand boom
got it and they and jeff distributes it
now it's his toilet paper bread
right he doesn't care he doesn't have an
ego about it he's like great thanks for
doing the r d i appreciate that
and so it's only the people who have the
the the ego
about being like i was the first one
like no one cares right
the only thing people care about is how
much money you make period and that you
are looking always for the next thing
and so
that's why that's what we came out with
hybrid right like that's the next thing
like
i think down the road group i mean group
training is not going away
but the price points will become
increasingly commoditized and the
pressure
will increase and the middle tier
players the lower tier players are going
to go out
right it's just what it is and so if i'm
helping the most amount of people i have
to create
the new or the next opportunity to shift
everyone into which is going to take the
next
seven years of gold rush until
eventually more and more people copy it
and then we'll come up with the next
because that's business right if you
want something that's gonna stick around
forever
don't be a business owner it's not gonna
work right same thing with marketing
so anyways all this to say the reason i
call this violence is the answer
uh is that massive action is the only
thing you can do
right it's the only it's the only combat
you have it's like success is the only
revenge
is that you just keep focusing on doing
you and increasing the amount of
opportunities increasing the percentage
that you capture
and decreasing the turn of your business
that is all you do that's all you focus
on and the rest of it does not matter
ignore it it doesn't matter the only way
that it starts to actually affect those
numbers if it takes up your headspace
it's the only way someone wins it's the
only way
and so if you don't want someone to win
right and someone talks [ __ ]
it's a client it's a trainer it's a
whatever a competitor
right first off understand that they're
not marketing to the people that you're
marketing to
they're not right and their little itty
bitty reach is irrelevant compared to
how much you're spending
and that's why we pay facebook because
they give us distribution right
just get that and then understand that
none of that is any way gonna affect
your business unless you allow it to
affect you
that's all so um that is why violence is
the answer
that is probably the single greatest
lesson that i that i learned and
witnessed from arnold
um and being in close proximity with him
obviously he talks about work now we
talked about business stuff we talked
about
charity talk for lots of things but the
principle
the essence that i feel like i got from
him was that he exists
on his own playing field he plays his
own game
and he just lets everyone else react and
that was
probably the single biggest takeaway
that i saw is that like when you get to
that level
you have to have this this level of
mental fortitude that is
almost delusional it borders on delusion
but the only difference between
crazy people and geniuses is that the
geniuses are right it's the only
difference right
and so like if you're like we're gonna
make it we're gonna make it we're making
and you do all of a sudden everything
you did before was sin
right and so if you have to exist in a
place where you're like don't show me
that stuff
if you have uh you know your managers or
your trainers are like hey this gym down
the street like talk [ __ ] about us right
if if they say that to you be like don't
show me that [ __ ] the only way that it
will actually affect our business
is if we talk about it because it
doesn't actually affect our business in
any way
are you closing sales tonight yeah i'm
are we marketing making more ads
yes right are you doing your the five
five four attention
yes great then let's just keep [ __ ]
wrong
right that's all that matters you keep
steam rolling forward and the thing that
pisses everyone else off is being
unfuckable
right you can't be [ __ ] with you just
keep going and keep going and then the
noise gets louder because they want a
reaction
and you just keep [ __ ] going right
you keep winning
because what you do is you focus as soon
as they get loud you focus
in you focus in on the things that drive
your business which is the math
right it's doing the work there's
nothing else right don't get in some
pissing match it doesn't matter
right just distracts you takes your
attention so
anyways um i hope that there's somebody
here who that affects i hope there's
somebody here who's dealing with a
trainer or dealing with a client or
dealing with a competitor
who's talking [ __ ] who's making posts
who's who's who who
like whenever you see that just be like
thanks for thinking about me bro i
appreciate that
you know thanks for talking about thanks
for keeping top of mind like much love
but you got to think like that because
that's the only way and that'll get even
more under there and now you're in their
minds
and they're not in yours because you
just keep doing what you need to do
and that's the only way you win so
anyways lots of everybody hope you have
an amazing thursday
and um keep being awesome i love you all
tomorrow's gonna be be so sick
[Music]
you